où
dimanche 10h dans les bois de rose l'est
un chasseur découvre le cadavre de
carole soltysiak 13 ans elle a disparu
la veille aux alentours de 17h30
son amie la voix pour la dernière fois à
quelques centaines de mètres de la cité
du vernois où résident ses parents elle
n'arrivera jamais jusque là les parents
s'inquiètent commence à prévenir la
famille en font des recherches et la
nuit tombante ne voyons pas carole
rentrée les parents au vent la
gendarmerie et signale sa disparition
c'est seulement le lendemain matin que
le corps de karol et donc retrouvé sans
vie à la lisière de ce bois dans de
macabres circonstances cette jeune fille
est dénudée elles portent que plaît dans
le thorax et le corps et partiellement
calciné
elle porte une sangle autour du cou et
la victime a été violée les enquêteurs
choqués par la scène décide d'utiliser
toutes les techniques scientifiques à
leur disposition à cette époque il
procède à de nombreux prélèvements sur
les lieux du crime
on découvre un poil sur le corps de la
victime qui est à poil qui identifier et
analyser c'est un poil masculin on va
trouver la présence de gasoil est un
alcool de bouche
c'est très important pour la suite de l'
enquête
ces découvertes donne de l'espoir aux
enquêteurs grâce à ces indices tous sont
persuadés qu'ils vont réussir à
retrouver le ou les auteurs sans tarder
on sent qu'il ya un vrai engagement
local sur ce sur ce crime
beaucoup de moyens vont être mis en
oeuvre et même on va pratiquer des tests
génétiques alors qu'on est au tout début
aux balbutiements de cette technique on
va chercher faire l'environnement
rechercher des témoignages vraiment
chercher dans toutes les directions
on se disait les éléments scientifiques
nous donneront les réponses à nos
questions et nous serons en mesure
rapidement de pouvoir annoncer à la
famille et bon qui a commis ces faits là
et pouvoir rapidement interpellé
le ou les suspects et pouvoir les
déférer devant une juridiction devant
une cour d'assises et puis
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
un an s'est écoulé depuis la mort de
carole et toujours rien c'est toute une
ville qui se mobilise en solidarité avec
la famille de la jeune fille assassinée
sa mère elisabeth soltysiak ne peut pas
s'y résoudre
elle fait tout son possible pour que le
meurtre de carole ne tombe pas dans
l'oubli
je me souviens dans les propos de madame
soltysiak disait sas rouge lui serre la
main à l'assassin de sa fille où je le
rencontre dans la rue il est derrière
moi au magasin elle voit le voyait
partout quoi
les années passent les pistes
s'enchaînent puis se referme la famille
de carole désespère et rejoint
l'association christelle pour mener le
combat
épaulé par d'autres mamans endeuillée
par le meurtre de leur fille en saône et
loire
elle suit les procédures et se bat avec
ses avocats
je vais sachs aille plus vite parce que
ça fait cinq ans presque six ans que
j'attends et je n'admets pas déjà
premièrement qu'il faut que quand deux
en aucun cas une questionnements des
plus deux ans quelques la pièce n'est
pas envoyée chez les avocats comprennent
quelqu'un pour s'occuper du dossier
cette détermination permet à lenquête
d'être relancé le nom d'un nouveau
suspect apparaît dans le dossier celui
de francis heaulme
mais faute de preuves la piste du tueur
en série est mise de côté
de nouvelles investigations finissent
par donner des résultats et des
témoignages permettent d'identifier deux
individus de noms qui circulent et qui
reviennent très vite il y en a 1
baptisée yacco et l'autre baptisée le
sphinx des jeunes de
la région de montceau qui forment une
bande cette banque qui est surnommé la
bande des gautherets on apprend que
cette bande squatter une ferme
curieusement cette ferme se la ferme due
aux les situé à 300 mètres du lieu de
découverte du corps
les deux hommes habitent toujours dans
la région les enquêteurs ont
suffisamment d'éléments pour les
interpeller l'un des deux suspects et
même obsédé par cette affaire il parle
souvent de la sphère carole tous les ans
au mois de novembre
il pleure on sait pas pourquoi il a
comme s'il avait un fardeau dont il
voulait se soulager le major jean gonnin
décide alors de le transporter sur les
lieux dix ans après les faits le sphinx
commence à parler
on fait le trajet il arrive dans le
quartier du vert-bois là je commence un
bout à des questions et il s'arrête à 10
mètres près là le petit copain de carole
l'avait laissé ce fameux samedi soir
inutile j'avais une bouteille de whisky
avec moi à l'arrière il y en a marre
spawn est parti dans un bois très
intéressant parce que là ils disent une
bouteille de whisky à la main
effectivement je vais mettre de l'alcool
sur le corps pour que le feu prenne or
qui pouvait savoir à ce moment là qu'on
avait découvert de l'alcool ce record
personne
cette information était en effet resté
confidentiel
yako et le sphinx sont alors mis en
examen pour le meurtre de carole
soltysiak mais les deux suspects ont des
profils psychologiques fragile ils sont
internés dans des centres spécialisés
ils reviennent sur leurs précédentes
déclarations et finissent par nier leur
implication
il ya toute une série de vérifications
police technique qu'on a sollicité donc
on va voir ce qui va être fait on a juge
d'instruction qui qui donne le sentiment
d'avoir envie d'avancer dans ce dossier
vingt-cinq ans après le meurtre de
l'adolescente
aucune condamnation n'a encore été
prononcée la famille de carroll a
désormais perdu tout espoir de justice
et ne souhaite plus s'exprimer dans les
médias
fatigué par toutes ces années de combat